j'ouvre tout de suite le second débat de
de ce sens public consacré à l'hommage
rendu aux victimes françaises des
attaques terroristes du Hamas le 7
octobre en Israël 42 de nos compatriotes
ont été tués comme avident torgem
bénévolle lors du festival euh tribe of
Nova abattu alors qu'il s'était caché
sous la scène ses parents qui habitent
dans un kibou sont venus à Paris avec
leurs filles pour participer à la
cérémonie dans la cour des Invalides
Fabien REER et myiam rockmassara
42 portraits dans la cour des Invalides
autant de viefuché le 7 octobre auquel
la France a rendu hommage ce matin il
n'avait pas 30 ans
Avidan Valentin
ou Naomi ne les auront jamais Avidan
Torjman avait 26 ans ses parents arrivés
d'Israël la veille salu la démarche de
l'hommage national un hommage qu'il juge
utile et on a un petit peu tendance à
oublier ceux qui sont tombés dès le
premier jour le 7 octobre il y a une
dynamique de combat une dynamique de
guerre malheureusement mais nous nous
restons avec notre notre deuil notre
tristesse et on doit essayer de
continuer le le quotidien
malgré cette catastrophe qui nous est
arrivée dans notre famille leur fils
avidane était bénévole au festival
supernova il s'était absenté quelques
heures de la fête avant de retourner sur
le site juste avant l'attaque pour pour
aider au démontage de la scène il s'est
caché sous la scène qu'ils avaient monté
et il a été en ligne avec notre fils
pendant 1h 40 ils étaient en ligne
jusqu'à ce que la la communication a été
coupée avidane était un jeune homme qui
adorait la vie qui méritait pas de
partir il avait tellement de choses à
faire et à donner et pas seulement lui
il n'y a pas une famille il n'y a pas
une personne en Israël qui n'a pas été
touché qui n'a pas un membre de la
famille un ami une connaissance un
collègue à qui c'est arrivé michaelll et
Monique torem appelle la France à
poursuivre la lutte contre le terrorisme
les gens veulent vivre nous on a donné
la vie à notre fils et pour qu'il puisse
continuer malheureusement à 26 ans sa
vie a été arrêtée et je crois qu'il y a
un problème international euh de fond
d'ententalisme islamique et euh et si on
fait rien ben ça va se passer partout
comme ça s'est déjà passé en France avec
l'aide de leur avocat les épous torgem
s'apprêtent à déposer une plainte en
France contre le Hamas pour crime contre
l'humanité PL iici on analyse tout de
suite le retentissement de cet hommage
ici en France en Israël ailleurs dans
dans le monde avec mes invités maître
yel c'est Mama bonsoir bienvenue vous
êtes avocate au barreau de Paris et donc
avocate de la famille David an torgem
assassiné par le Hamas au festival Nova
Roger kucci bonsoir bonsoir bienvenue à
vous sénateur LRD haut scène offer
Bonstein bonsoir et bienvenue vous êtes
le Pr du Forum international pour la
paix Mathieu croissant l'uditorialiste
politique est resté à mes côtés y m que
représente cette journée pour la famille
torem et peut-être plus généralement
pour toutes les familles qui étaient là
aux Invalides
eu la famille torem a exprimé ce matin
la
reconnaissance cette cette cérémonie
était pour eux vraiment un acte de de
leur reconnaissance en tant que Français
en tant que membre de notre nation et
cet hommage de la nation à à à leur fils
et à tout et à tous les les les disparus
c'était vraiment reprendre leur place
dans la nation française parce qu'ils
n'ont jamais quitté euh d'ailleurs
Emmanuel Macron a dit ce matin j'espère
ne pas il a dit qu'il ne certains ne
sont pas né en France ne sont pas tombés
sous le ciel de France mais il a dit
notre pays était partout où ils étaient
et à peu près hein j'ai noté voilà et je
pense que c'est exactement ça ce qu' ils
ont ressenti que la France est là où ils
sont et on en parlera tout à l'heure
avec les actions judiciaires qu'on peut
mener en France mais c'était
effectivement le sentiment et un
sentiment partagé qu'on a pu entendre
dans les gradins tout à l'heure et
ensuite lorsque les familles étaient
face à à Emmanuel Macron cet hommage de
la France au aux victimes du 7 octobre
était diffusé en direct à télavis on va
voir quelques images de cette diffusion
euh donc c'était à la mi-journée hein en
direct à téléaviv sur cette place des
otages qui est située en face du
ministère de de la défense euh Roger
carochi la France est le premier pays
étranger à organisé un un hommage
national quel symbole vous vous associez
à cette à cette journée est-ce que vous
dites enfin comment comment vous
réagissez je peux dire enfin et tant
mieux enfin parce que effectivement
c'était il y a quand même déjà plusieurs
mois et le groupe France Israël du Sénat
par exemple que je préside avait demandé
cet hommage déjà depuis le début c'est
bien et c'est encore mieux d'être le
premier mais c'est aussi parce que nous
sommes l'un des pays qui malheureusement
a le plus de
morts problème c'est aussi ça nous avons
42 franco-israéliens qui ont été tués et
par définition nous sommes en dehors de
ceux qui sont purement israéliens qui
n'ont pas de double nationalité nous
voilà on est le pays le plus touché donc
c'est assez logique qu'on soit aussi le
plus concerné le plus impliqué je vous
rappelle qu'il y a toujours et enc c euh
énormément de franco-israéliens en
Israël je de mémoire ils doivent être à
peu près 120000 ce qui est quandme
150000 250000 donc voyez c'est quand
même considérable c'est normal que la
France soit le premier tant mieux bon
voilà c'est très bien même si euh on
aurait pu imaginer cela plutôt mais bon
ne faisons pas la fine bouche c'est bien
de l'avoir faiter Bronstein ça dit aussi
effectivement des liens entre la société
française et la société israélienne je
n'ai aucun doute j'ai parlé avec
beaucoup d'amis israéliens et compris
avec le président herzock cet après-midi
qui a tout de suite envoyé un message il
devait être là mais parce qu' a une
visite du président arenttin en Israël
il n'a pas pu se faire le déplacement
mais il a tout de suite envoyé un
message au président Macron pas
seulement ça va à mon avis c'est ça va
être un tournant dans la dans la
relation entre entre la France et Israël
l'émotion que ça a suscité en Israël
bien entendu ça a suscité énormément
d'émotion ici en France mais l'émotion
que ça sucité en Israël a été
extraordinaire les mots que que le que
le président a choisit pour dire les
choses ont touché le le cœur des
Israéliens donc je je pense que c'est
encore une preuve de l'amitié qui existe
entre les deux pays et c'est pas
seulement ça le le président Macron la
question s'est posée pourquoi maintenant
moi je l'ai accompagné fin octobre la
première tournée qu'il a fait dans la
région a visité Israël ramala Aman et le
Ker on lui avait déjà reproché à
l'époque il allit trop tardilles on lui
a reproché d'y aller trop tard mais lui
il voulait je sais je sais exactement
pourquoi il est allé après certains
c'est que lui il voulait faire la
tournée il avait déjà une vision
régionale de la solution il ne voulait
pas uniquement venir aller dans un kibut
exprimer sa sa tristesse et repartir il
voulait être dans le concret c'est pour
ça qu'il a retardé son son son voyage
mais il ait déjà à l'aéroport de l'ode
où les familles l'attendait quand on a
atterri il avait déjà promis aux
familles qu'il y aurait un hommage
national si a pas fait c'est qu'on
savait pas et j'espère que la liste des
morts français s'est terminée là parce
que n'oubliez pas que nous avons encore
trois otages franco-israélien j'espère
qu'ils sont vivants j'espère qu'ils
seront libérés mais une des raisons pour
laquelle il a attendu c'est de vous de
ne pas faire trop vite un hommage alors
que qu'on on était incertain par rapport
à une bonne partie des des otages mais
j'ai j'ai aucun doute que la relation
entre la France et Israël après tour là
aujourd'hui on va en reparler de ça
monieur je trouve paradoxalement que ce
décalage dans le temps a donné au
discours davantage de puissance alors
que moi je m'interrogeais aussi comme
beaucoup en se disant qu'est-ce qu'il
fait pourquoi il y a pas dommage mais
s'il l'avait fait euh au lendemain des
attaques du 7 octobre ou dans les jours
qui ont suivi ça aurait été une émotion
parmi les émotions le faire 4 mois après
un moment où le conflit devient confus
pour une grande partie de l'opinion avec
les mots qu'il a choisi je pense que ça
a donné à son discours encore plus de
pertinence et encore plus de de de
puissance avec pour les familles
présentes dans la cour des Invalides cet
espoir que voilà il y aura peut-être
d'autres pays qui organiseront des
hommages similaires retentissement
mondial écoutez isaidan qui a perdu deux
de ses neveux dans l'attaque et son
frère on parlait des otages son frère
est toujours otage du Hamas
j'espère que ça se retendra dans tout le
monde pas seulement en France j'espère
que les autres essayeront de faire la
même chose dans leur pays je crois que
de ce point de vue la France a donné le
grand signe le grand signe de de de
d'être avec ceux qui
ont reçu un très très grand
coup votre avis Roger
kucci sur ce que nous disait ferbrstein
à l'instant les les est-ce que c'est une
nouvelle étape importante ou une
nouvelle page qui s'ouvre dans les
relations entre la France et Israël je
crains malheureusement que non h euh
bien sûr il y a l'émotion et l'émotion
elle est partagée forcément euh les
familles israéliennes les autorités
israéliennes sont sensibles au fait que
nous soyons le premier pays après euh la
réalité de la politique internationale
elle n'est pas que dans l'émotion HM
après euh qu'est-ce qui sera proposé sur
l'après-guerre sur le cesser le feu sur
le sort de Gaza il est évident que sur
ces sujets on sait très bien qu'il y a
une différence considérable
d'appréciation entre la France et Israël
euh il y aura pas forcément un
rapprochement très clair là-dessus donc
attendons de voir un petit peu ce que
donne la suite quand vous êtes allé en
Israël parce que vous faisiez partie de
la délégation sénatoriale qui s'y est
rendu vous n'avez pas senti une une
attente particulière de la part de la
France de l'engagement français de
l'action de sa
diplomatie pour être tout à fait franc
ouais allez-y non bon non on a rencontré
le président de état d'Israël bien sûr
longuement un certain nombre de
responsables politiques y compris
l'opposition d'ailleurs et et des
responsables militaires euh c'est
évident que quand le pays est en guerre
il compte plus les avions et les
porortesavions Américains qui sont à
proximité que la diplomatie française le
ministre d'affaires étrangères français
reconnaît que par exemple il est
intervenu auprès du Liban pour dire
attention israël veut pas la guerre mais
faites attention à la frontière mais on
on sent que la France peut servir
d'intermédiaire
elle n'est plus un acteur très direct et
lourd
dans je vois que vous voulez réagir donc
allez-y au faire je suis en total
désaccord avec Monsieur droit et je vais
je vais le et je vais le prouver par par
par des faits et par rapport à à cette
terrible guerre dans laquelle on se
trouve dès le 7 octobre au soir à la
demande des Israéliens je le sais parce
que c'est à travers moi que cette
demande est passée on a sollicité le
présid prident Macron pour qu'il
intervienne auprès des Qataris pour
qu'il intervienne auprès des Libanais on
avait très peur on a toujours très peur
que que ça s'embrasse dans la région
plus que les escamou sonre Israël et le
Lian sont
quotidiennes il n'y a pas un jour il y a
pas un jour depuis le 7 octobre que que
le président Macron ne prend pas le
téléphone pour parler à maintenant jeis
donner encore un exemple qui est inédit
dans la relation entre la France et
Israël ce n'est pas par hasard que tous
les patrons des services de
renseignement l'Américain le Qatari
l'égyptien l'Israélien et d'autres se
sont retrouvés à Paris il y a 10 jours
pour parler des des otages donc ils ont
senti dans ils ont ils ont senti qu'en
France ils pouvir P il pouvaient trouver
les appuis et la confiance nécessaire
pour que ça se passe ce n'est pas un
hasard Israël est très reconnaissante
que c'est la France qui a pris
l'initiative d'amener des des
médicaments aux otages on espère qu'ils
sont arrivés aux otages mais c'est une
initiative française maintenant je peux
vous vous savez encore une fois ces
quatre dernières années les relations
économiques entre la France et Israël
ont quatruplé donc il y a des relations
s entre la France et Israël je pense que
le président Macron est très respecté
par Israël et j'espère que ça continuera
comme ça maintenant politiquement
permettez-moi une remarque n'oubliez pas
que beaucoup d'autres thèm AB je voyais
où parce que je le seul président
français qui a reconnu qui a reconnu
l'État palestinien vous savez lequel
c'était c'était le président Sarkozi à
l'Unesco le président Sarkozi a reconnu
la Palestine comme état à part entière à
l'Unesco euh donc euh euh il y a la
politique et a la réelle politique s
allez on on on reparlera parce qu'il y a
quand même l'une des informations
aujourd'hui c'est la l'hypothèse
l'espoir que qu'une nouvelle phase de
négociation euh peut-être une trêve
puisse aboutir à la Libération d'otage
on en reparlera dans un instant mais je
voudrais revenir sur alors là vraiment
sur la perception de cet hommage ici en
France euh avec d'abord un sondage qui a
été euh réalisé par euh Aris interactif
pour le le CRIF le Conseil représentatif
des institutions juives de de France qui
dit que les Français euh répondent oui
majoritairement à la question il a-t-il
eu des des Français parmi les les les
tués lors de l'attaque du Hamas mais ce
qui est intéressant c'est que quand on
on leur demande combien de de français
ont été tués là les réponses sont
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup plus floues
il y a 45 % des des des personnes
interrogées qui pensent qu'il y a eu de
moins de 10 français qui ont été tués et
seulement 11 % qui sont dans la
malheureusement la la la la bonne
fourchette pardon de ce terme de de 40 à
49 français et le président du CRIF
Jonathan harfy espère que cet hommage
national qu'on a vécu aujourd'hui ce
midi va changer la donne écoutons-le 42
français c'est le nombre de
ressortissants étrangers en dehors
évidemment donc des Israéliens qui est
le plus élevé il y a eu plus de Français
tués ce jour-là que d'Américains que
d'Allemands que d'anglais et ça dit
quelque chose à la fois des liens qui
existent entre la société française et
la société israélienne et cette ce
manque de prise de conscience pour une
partie des Français du fait que c'est la
le plus meurtrier contre des Français
depuis l'attendat de Nice et bien
j'espère que l'hommage national va
permettre de le combler que ça va
permettre de faire rentrer ses noms ses
visages ses destins dans notre mémoire
collective votre avis là-dessus c'est M
est-ce que cette journée a rempli en
partie ce cette mission oui tout à fait
je je partage le point de vue de
Jonathan Arfi vous savez mais la famille
torgem m'a dit quelque chose qui m'a
beaucoup touché elle m'a dit voilà on
parle beaucoup des otages évidemment et
et bien bien sûr et on on on parle
beaucoup des soldats tomb qui tombent à
Gaza en Israël on parle déjà moins des
morts donc déjà en Israël on parle déjà
moins des morts parce que on est pris
dans le combat pour la libération des
otages on est pris par la tristesse et
venir en France et parler et montrer le
visage des victimes françaises et et et
de leurs enfants c'était remettre un nom
sur eux personnaliser raconter une
histoire et j'espère que effectivement
le défilé des portraits des victimes
dans la cour des Invalides dans la cour
d'honneur porté par la Garde
Républicaine ça avait vraiment un sens
et ça redonnait à chacun et ça permet
aux Français de visualiser
d'individualiser de personnaliser
Emmanuel Macron qui a employé cette
expression le plus grand massacre
antisémite de notre siècle on écoute un
extrait du discours du président de la
République il était
6h et le Hamas lança par
surprise l'attaque massive et
odieuse le plus grand massacre
antisémite de notre
siècle et dans les notes de musique d'un
lieu de fête ont éclaté les tambours de
l'enfer et les téléphones de nos enfants
qui jusque-là filmai les joies de leur
vie sont devenu les boîtes noires de
l'horreur elles nous entront ces
image le ciel livide qui se zèbre de
missile les brigades infernales qui
écument le festival se répandent dans
les plaines puis dans les villages
fracassent les portes font irruption
dans les foyers dans les chambres sous
les lits les déflagrations les cris de
massacrons les Juifs les grenades les
hurlements les pleurs puis le
silence comme un
linceul y c'est Mama vous a vous allez
déposer je crois une plainte au nom de
la famille torgem pour crime contre
l'humanité on va dans ce débat beaucoup
parler des mots qu'on peut comment
qualifier ce qui s'est ce qui s'est
passé et peut-être aussi d'ailleurs on
va en parler ce qui se passe à Gaza avec
la la ripos militaire israélienne
d'abord plainte contre crime combité ici
en France pourquoi en France alors la
loi française prévoit ce qu'on appelle
la compétence personnelle passive alors
c'est un mot un peu une expressionion un
peu compliqué pour dire une chose très
simple un citoyen français qui est
victime d'un d'un d'un crime ou de
certains délits aussi euh commis à
l'étranger par un étranger ou par un
Français peu importe euh est éigible
entre guillemets à à ce que son à ce que
ce crime soit examiné par les juridican
les juridictions françaises donc tout
citoyen français tire de la loi
française ce droit à ce que le crime en
l'occurrence ce crime contre l'humanité
fasse l'objet aujourd'hui et c'est ce
que l'on souhaite d' d'une enquête d'une
instruction et peut-être un jour d'un
jugement euh des euh responsables de ce
massacre du Hamas des brigades AZ
alkassem et cetera euh Roger cauchci ces
mots CRIM contre l'humanité euh vous les
avez entloyé euh très vite et vous avez
regretté qu'il ne le soit pas forcément
par euh euh le chef de l'État ou à
l'époque ou la la ministre des Affaires
étrangères pour exactement oui dans
l'hémicycle lors d'une question
d'actualité mais qui remonte déjà au
mois d'octobre hein euh j'avais reproché
au gouvernement à Madame Colona à
l'époque mais aussi au Premier ministre
enfin à l'époque à la premire ministre
de ne pas utiliser dans l'hémicycle les
termes de crime contre mais parce que
euh je je l'ai dit à ce moment-là
d'ailleurs mal qualifieré un axe c'est
déjà le ni et donc je je vois pas en
quoi le massacre du 7 octobre est un
crime de guerre je veux dire c'est plus
qu'un crime de guerre
le massacre n'est pas par rapport à des
soldats c'est par rapport à des familles
à des gosses à des femmes enceintes des
femmes cour les viols les décapitations
le massacre ça n'est pas un acte de
guerre alors et ça revenait aussi
quelque part à dire est-ce que le ramass
quand on dit crime de guerre est-ce que
le ramass est pas reconnu comme un
acteur de guerre et non pas comme un
mouvement terroriste donc moi je
considère que c'est un crime contre
l'humanité
dev l'y depuisob alors ces mots utilisés
choisis pour qualifier les les massacres
du 7 octobre c'est aussi au cœur d'une
polémique qui concerne le parti de
jean-l Mélenchon Mathieu des élus de la
France insoumise se sont finalement
rendus à cet hommage national oui et
entre nous on se demandait bien ce qu'il
fichait là plusieurs familles de
victimes avaent écrit jusqu'au président
de la République pour lui demander
d'interdire la présence de LFI à
l'hommage national et ce seul argument
aurait dû suffire en particulier dans un
pays dans un parti pardon qui se Targ de
placer l'humain d'abord au-dessus de
tout car s'il y a bien une valeur
partagée dans l'humanité toute entière
c'est bien le respect du deuil on
n'ajoute pas de la douleur à du chagrin
on najoute pas de la colère à la
souffrance on respecte on écoute les
proches on nimpose pas sa présence pour
reprendre les mots du député insoumis de
de la Somme François Ruffin isolé dans
son propre camp des parents qui pleurent
leurs enfants ont tous les droits que
reprochaient précisément les familles à
la France insoumise indescence absence
de resp relativisme et négationnisme et
il est difficile de leur donner tort je
rappelle à toutes fins utiles que pour
le groupe parlementaire LFI l'attaque du
7 octobre fut ou guillemets une
offensive armée de forces palestiniennes
c'est écrit noir sur blanc dans leur
communiqué ce jour-là ouvre les
guillemets dans l'attaque du Hamas il y
avait quatre casernes qui étaient visé
et une Rê qui a dit ça Jean-Luc
Mélenchon le 2 décembre sur France
interre passant sous silence les
massacres des kibuts il ne s'agiss donc
pas de terrorisme aux yeux des insoumis
mais selon les explications àambiqué de
Mathilde Panau le 10 octobre de crime de
guerre qui vise à la terreur je referme
les guillemets perpétré ouvre les
guillemets par la branche armée du Hamas
le Hamas ouvre et les guillemets un
mouvement de résistance qui se définit
comme tel selon les mots le 17 octobre
de Daniel auonau j'aurais pu arrêter là
j'aurais pu aussi continuer en ajoutant
les élucubration monstrueuse du député
du Nord David guireud les rires nerveux
de sa collègue du Valdemar il souet les
appels répétés de Thomas port de sa
saint-is à traduire en justice à traîner
en justice l'État hébreu et même
maintenant les Franco israélien de tsal
coupable à ses yeux de CRIM de guerre
alors que pas j'entends pas beaucoup
d'appel à traîner en justice les
responsables planqués du Hamas au Qatar
j'aurais pu ajouter aussi la dernière en
date celle d'hier soir signée Emeric
Caron qui appelait le CO à contraindre
les atraites Israéliens à défilé sans
drapeau comme ceux de la Russie de
Poutine en toute confusion il a oublé
muni he ouais Emeric Caron qui a
d'ailleurs été siffléé à son arrivée aux
Invalides pourquoi alors jeis vous
donner la parole pourquoi ils s sont
rendus con trompe pas leur présence
n'est ni le signe d'une soudaine
compassion ni d'un revirement ni d'un
repentir mais le fruit d'un arbitrage
parce que les insoumis qui considèr que
tout est politique et qu'en politique on
ne s'excuse jamais ont donc jugé qu'ils
avaient plus à perdre à ne pas s'y
rendre alors ils y sont allés vous
l'avez dit Thomas sous les hués et sous
la colère de ceux qui étaient là
poussant encore un peu plus les limites
de l'indécence
ferbin par rapport par rapport au est-ce
qu'il faut attaquer le Hamas pour crime
contre l'humanité contre de guerre je
suis je suis d'accord avec avec monsieur
le sénateur mais je voulais vous
rappeler que le Hamas a déjà été
condamné et si je ne me trompe pas en
2012 par la Cour pénale internationale
je ne sais pas si c'était pour crime de
guerre ou crime contre l'humanité je
rappelle encore une chose la communauté
internationale reconnaît et et que le
khamas c'est une organisation terroriste
maintenant moi ce que je voudrais c'est
pas qu'une avocate qui qui représente
une famille franco-israélienne et porte
plainte que ce soit les palistiniens qui
portent plainte contre le Hamas c'est
les Palestiniens qui sont les premiers
c'est les Palestiniens qui sont les
premières victimes du Hamas c'est le
Hamas qui a voulu que cette guerre
devienne si
si le
ramas les Palestiniens sont les
premières victime
du D' non je dis pas jeis pas je non non
c'est c'est pas du tout c'était pas du
tout mon inention c'est que je dis
regardez ce qui arrive à
gaz pourquoi ne le font-ils pas porter
plainte contre la masse parce que ils
vivent sous la Terreur parce que aussi
aussi aussi parce qu'ils vivent sous la
Terreur aussi parce qu'ils vivent sous
la moi je je je l'ai toujours dit et je
le répète l'ennemi des Palestiniens
c'est la pauvreté et l'ignorance et la
corruption quand on vit dans la pauvreté
dans laignorance et dans la corruption
du Hamas on est complètement
déabillé est complètement démuni et les
pauvres Palestiniens souffrent de ça la
plupart des Palestiniens ne sont pas des
terroristes je veux qu'ils vivent en
paix avec mes enfants et
j'espère et continua à être mon combat
votre avis
surev F alors Monique Michel torgem ont
signé cette lettre adressée à Emmanuel
Macron en demandant que que que les f ne
soit pas présent c'est pas un acte
politique c'était vraiment une réaction
épidermique
la seule la seule la seule idée qu'il
puisse assister à cet hommage les les
les rendait absolument nerveux et et
s'inquiéta même de leur présence mais
moi ce que je voudrais dire c'est que
finalement à titre personnel je ne
regrette pas leur présence ils ont
entendu dans la cour d'honneur des
Invalides qu'on parlait d'un du plus
grand massacre
antisémite et ce seul fait qu'il l'IT
entendu que ça a raisonné et qu'il n'ait
pas pu prendre la parole pour le dire
pour moi c'est et pour pour les familles
c'était un moment extrêmement important
et oui mais malheureusement
malheureusement je crains qu'il ne
comprennent pas on verra d'abord parce
que Jean-Luc Mélenchon a dit lui-même il
y a quelques jours que pour lui c'était
pas un massacre antisémite parce que les
les les alors je dis moi les terroristes
c'est pas le mot qu'il a employé du
ramas lui a affirmé qu'il les ont tué
parce que israéliens et non pas juifs
alors je voudrais alors non non mais
juste pour vous dire que que que le
président Mac et que l'ensemble de la
communauté nationale dise c'est le plus
grand massacre antisémite pogrom que
l'on est connu c'est c'est clairement ce
que chacun pense mais dans un côté allez
soyons franc clientéliste
électoraliste la France
insoumise frise constamment sur
l'antisémitisme et non pas seulement sur
l'antiionisme et à partir du moment où
c'est
constant bien sûr qu'on peut leur dire
devant eux que c'est le plus grand
massacre antisémite pour autant vous
verrez que dès demain euh ils vont
demander autre chose un mot de
conclusion sur ce M oui absolument en
tout cas moi ce que je voudrais dire
c'est que le le le fait de qualifier les
actes perprétés le 7 octobre de massacre
antisémite ça a un vrai sens et ça a un
sens juridique pourquoi parce
qu'aujourd'hui on travaille même avec
des confrères sur l'idée de porter plein
nom pas simplement pour crime contre
l'humanité mais crime contre l'humanité
avec une intention génocidaire parce que
et et et là si vous voulez
malheureusement j'ai eu à voir ce film
terrible hein qu' non pas NVA le film
vous savez moi j'ai j'ai entendu
seulement youd Kalb les Juifs sont des
sont des chiens je n'ai pas entendu
parler je n'ai pas entendu le mot
Palestine je n'ai pas entendu le mot
israélien je par que disent les
terroristes ou moi je parlehébreux j'ai
même des notions d'arabe je veux dire on
avait des sous-titres euh alors
aujourd'hui on peut même se poser cette
question si ce crime cont contre
l'humanité n'a pas été commis dans une
intention génocidaire contre un group
bien déterminé les Juifs alors on va
rester sur ces sur ces notions et
toujours sur finalement des des question
sémantique et là je reviens à la
question hommage national c'est ce qui
s'est passé aujourd'hui temps mémoriel
voilà les les termes qui ont été
employés par l'élyisée pour annoncer
qu'il y aura un temps mémoriel pour les
français morts sous les bombes
israélienne à Gaza ça a été fait lundi
cette annonce par l'Élysée pour l'ancien
président François
temps mémoriel et pas hommage national
il éta invité ce matin de France Info la
nuance est importante on écoute j'ai
entendu cette proposition ça ne peut pas
être le même hommage une vie est une vie
et et une vie est équivalente à une
autre vie mais il y a les victimes du
terrorisme et les victimes de guerre
pour les victimes du terrorisme il y a
toujours eu des hommages pour les
victimes de guerre il peut y avoir à un
moment des cérémonies mais ce n'est pas
le même processus être une une victime
du terrorisme c'est d'une certaine façon
être là parce que nous sommes français
être attaqué en tant que Français ou en
tant que défenseur d'un mode de vie
victime collatérale vous êtes dans une
guerre vous êtes victime collatérale il
y en a en Ukraine ce n'est pas un acte
de terrorisme on peut dire que c'est un
acte de guerre on peut dire que on ne
sommes pas d'accord sur cette fuite en
avant nous pouvons considérer que ça met
en cause des populations civiles que
c'est inacceptable on peut dire que il y
a des des situations humanitaires
intolérables qui se passent à Gaza mais
ce n'est pas de même nature Roger kucci
votre avis temps mémoriel pour les
victimes françaises des bombardements
israéliens à Gaza on est vraiment dans
la sémantique je ne sais pas quelle
forme ça prendra d'abord attendons de
voir pour le moment on a vu ce qui était
évidemment l'hommage aux invalide il
faut le faire vous irez ah non vous
n'irez pas non non je n'irai pas
pourquoi parce que j'attends de voir la
forme que ça prendra soyons Fran si
c'est la forme équivalente entre
guillemets avec je sais pas parce que
l'appellation temps mémoriel ça ne
signifie en réalité institutionnellement
rien ça n'existe pas en fait donc est-ce
que c'est un temps mémoriel quand même
aux Invalides c'estàd est-ce qu'on met
sur le même plan les deux actes le 7
octobre et la suite si c'est ça je
n'irai pas si en revanche c'est un temps
mémoriel parce qu'il y a des Français
qui sont morts mais alors il faudra que
le Président de la République définisse
la manière dont ce sera rendu si c'est
juste un hommage à des français morts
éventuellement j'irai mais j'attends de
voir ce que ça veut dire mais je ne veut
pas qu'on mette les deux éléments sur le
même plan alors euh je vais rappeler un
chiffre alors c'est celui du Hamas
évidemment il est à prendre avec
énormément de pincettes plus de 27000
morts dans la bande de gaz c'est
impossible à vérifier aujourd'hui ce
chiffre mais bon de toute façon il y a
des il y a des des milliers peut-être
dizaines de milliers de morts là-bas je
voudrais qu'on parle de la qualification
de de ce qui se passe depuis 4 mois à
Gaza et je me tourne vers vers vous
offer au brstein parce que c'est devenu
un enjeu géopolitique il y a une plainte
qui a été déposée par l'Afrique du Sud
contre Israël devant la Cour euh de
international de justice de l'ONU
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de cette
plainte plainte pour génocide on on
retrouve les mêmes mots tout d'abord
c'est pas anodin que la plainte a été
déposée par par par l'Afrique du Sud oui
euh je pense que l'Afrique du Sud a
encore beaucoup de travail à faire sur
elle-même euh par rapport à son passé
j'espère que qu'elle qu'elle qu'elle
qu'elle le fait euh en plus il y a eu
déjà une décision de la cour de de de la
cour euh qui ne parle pas de génocide
qui demande aux Israéliens de vérifier
ce qui s'est passé de et de revenir et
lui communiquer qui ne demande
d'ailleurs il faut le préciser la Cour
ne demande même pas d'arrêter la guerre
donc euh je regrette qu'on en arrive là
vous savez je comprends maître je je je
suppose qu'à un moment donné il y aura
une dimension juridique international et
cetera en fin de compte le problème il
est politique quand on décidera
d'arrêter et quand on décidera de se
réconcilier et quand on décidera de se
de reconstruire et quand on aura terminé
de pleurer nos morts et de et de soigner
nos blessés et de de guérir no
traumatisme c'est ça sera pas une action
politique moi je ne cherche pas
aujourd'hui à régler des comptes avec
qui que ce soit moi ce que je veux
aujourd'hui c'est que les otages
israéliens reviennent chez eux à la
maison que que qu'Israël ne soit plus
victime de milliers de missiles qui sont
jetés sur elle et du Nord ou du Sud eu
que que qu'elle puisse vivre en bonne
relation avec tous ses voisins et je
cherche la même chose pour les
Palestiniens qu' un enfant palestinien
qui a vu sa maison détruite qui a vu
peut-être son père ou son frère et tué
dans cette terrible guerre garde
l'espoir pour un meilleur pour pour un
avenir meilleur parce que je ne veux pas
que cet enfant devienne lui aussi un
terroriste en 20 ans donc on a du
travail à faire et je pense que le
travail principal à faire est sur le
chemin politique j'espère qu'il y aura
une volonté une détermination politique
de la part de la communauté
internationale en par parulier de la
France des États-Unis et de l'Europe
pour une fois pour toutes faire venir
les je crois pas que les Israéliens les
Palestiniens peuvent s'arranger tout
seul à ce stade il y a trop de poison
qui circulle qui a contaminé le cœur des
Israéliens et des Palestiniens je le
comprends donc il va falloir que la
communauté internationale dise basta on
est capable d'aller sur Mars on n pas
capable de régler ce problème c'est
c'est c'est impensable on va y revenir
dans un instant parce qu'on va parler
des otages avec Samia Deir et de cette
peut-être ouverture on l'espère d'une
d'une fenêtre pour que il a de nouveau
une trêve et des libération d'otage mais
je voudrais et peut-être que ça va vous
choquer mais reprendre une expression
que plusieurs universitaires qu'on a
invité sur ce plateau on l'entend aussi
cette expression dans les couloirs de de
l'ONU c'est pas anodin pour qualifier
l'action de l'armée israélienne à Gaza
depuis 4 mois cette expression c'est une
expression c'est un nettoyage ethnique
pratiqué à Gaza qu'est-ce que vous
répondez à cette expression écoutez en
arrivant ici je m'étais dit que je ne
voudrais pas parler du conflit à Gaza
que ce n'était pas ma place que ce
n'était pas mon rôle vous m'interrogez
sur un oui parce
que la question de la qualifation
question qualification je voudrais dire
à Monsieur brin qu'on a qu'on partage le
même le même but je suis persuadé voilà
et que je je voudrais que vous AZ Rais
d'accord on vu d'ord voudrais que vous
ayez raison je voudrait que tout ne soit
que
politique et que tout se résoudra par la
politique la et que ça ne se passe pas
ainsi à quoi sert la justice
elle sert aussi et je je rejoins
monsieur pardi à mettre des mots sur ce
qui s'est passé et ne pas les mettre et
je vous rejoins aussi c'est les
minimiser alors nettoyage ethnique non
je peux absolument pas adhérer et je
vais vous dire sans considération du
fait que mon cœur puisse être aussi en
Israël pour de multiples raisons euh il
n'y a pas d'intention et c'est le le le
le principe je pense l'élément principal
de procéder d'une quelconque manière à
l'élimination d'un groupe par rapport à
une appartenance ethnique ou même
géographique on est à ce moment-là de
conflits dans une guerre et il n'y a pas
de volonté le nettoyage ethnique repose
sur une intention
d'éliminer un groupe par son
appartenance et là je crois que vraiment
on ne peut pas y être je parce on
pourrait faire ceès à benam non non non
je va dire je vais vous donner des
exemples concrets pourquoi ça peut
l'être et et je ne veux pas faire
l'avocat du diable mais je je ne peux
pas m'en empêcher malheureusement
malheureusement pour moi en tant que
franco-israélien c'est une honte il y a
à l'intérieur du gouvernement israélien
euh des ministres qui sont des fascistes
et ces gens-là qui s'expriment en disant
faut mettre une bombe atomique sur Gaza
c'est du nettoyage ethnique c'est une
volonté de de cri contre l'humanité et
ce n'est pas les seuls et c'est pas des
isolés c'est le ministre des Finances
c'est le ministre de la police
intérieure c'est des gens qui sont qui
font au cœur du gouvernement israëlien
ils me font honte en tant que juif ils
me font honte en tant qu'israëlien et
c'est des gens qui qui appellent au GéCi
des Palestiniens allez on va terminer ce
débat sur le sort des otages et je vous
propose pour commencer d'entendre
l'ambassadrice d'Israël ici à Paris elle
rappelle ce que voilà ce qu'on peut tous
imag 4 mois de cauchemar pour les
familles c'était sur BFM TV ce matin je
pense aux familles hier j'ai eu une
rencontre avec avec les familles des
otages français qui sont là sont donc
arrivés hier soir à Paris c'est un
cauchemar qu'ils vivent pendant 4 mois
c'est une torture psychologique et
sachant que leurs chaires sont là on n
pas de nouvelle de leur sort aucun
nouvelle on sait même pas si les
médicaments offerts initié par le
président Macron ont été reçus et par
les otages aucun nouvelle on sait bien
qu'ils ont été torturés et qu'ils sont
toujours torturés là-bas donc vraiment
ce sont 4 mois de cauchemars permanents
pour eux et ce qui est important pour
nous c'est être sûr rassuré qu'ils vont
être qu'ils pourront retourner chez eux
prochainement le plus vite
possible Samia de Ch bonsoir combien de
d'otage reste encore aux mains du Hamas
et bien d'après l'état hébreu il reste
encore 100 32 otages à Gaza 132 otages
dont 29 seraient décédés parmi les
otages encore au mains de l'organisation
terroriste il y aurait trois Français
qui sont toujours portés disparu et donc
présumés otage à la base je rappelle que
250 personnes ont été capturés par le
Hamas lors de cette attaque du 7 octobre
qu'une centaine d'entre eux a déjà été
libérés fin novembre après la conclusion
d'une trêve entre Israël et le Hamas et
l'enjeu Thomas c'est donc la libération
de nouveaux hô avec donc cet espoir d'un
nouvel accord en perspective oui le
secrétaire d'État américain Anthony
blinken s'est entretenu aujourd'hui avec
les dirigeants israéliens à propos d'une
proposition de trêve une proposition qui
a été formulée par les États-Unis le
Qatar et l'Égypte le médiateur qatari
assure que le Hamas serait prêt à signer
cet accord alors qu' a-t-il dans cet
accord bien d'après une source
palestinienne citée par la FP cet accord
prévoit une trêve de 6 semain dans les
combats la libération de 200 à 300
prisonniers palestiniens cet accord
prévoit aussi l'entrée accrue d'aide
humanitaire dans la bande de Gaza et
enfin la libération potentielle de 35 à
40 otages israen enfin otage détenu par
le Hamas oui et on va rappeler que pour
l'instant évidemment rien n'est signé
oui il faut donc prendre toutes ces
informations là avec beaucoup de
prudence le Hamas confirme juste en fait
avoir donné sa réponse on ne sait pas si
elle est positive ou né négative on
attend donc encore la réponse d'Israël
dans tous les cas il n'y aura pas de
cesser le feu définitif comme le réclamé
le Hamas Israël n'acceptera qu'une trêve
provisoire il a déjà prévenu donc cet
accord n'est pas signé et les lignes
peuvent encore bouger évidemment ça peut
encore bouger merci beaucoup Samia Roger
carucci votre avis sur ce qui est en
train de se s tractation d'abord
clairement on sait que demain commence
des négociations au C entre justement
les États-Unis le Qatar Israël h manière
directe ou indirecte donc on va bien
voir ce que ça donne la seule inquiétude
enfin l'inquiétude moi je rêverai que la
paix soit rétablie que la trêve
s'installe et que les otages reviennent
et que tout ça s'arrête parce
que c'est un cauchemar pour tout le
monde c'est un cauchemar pour les
Israéliens c'est un cauchemar pour les
Palestiniens pour ceux qui ne souhaitent
pas cette guerre et qui sont sous la
contrainte du ramas c'est un cauchemar
donc il faut trouver une solution un
élément d'inquiétude quand même parce
que le ramas visiblement quand Israël
demande et dit par exemple trêve
d'accord mais libération de tous les
aotagees et c'est ok pour libérer plus
de de Palestiniens prison on voit bien
que le ramas ne dit jamais tous les
otages dit 35 40 est-ce que ça veut dire
que les autres sont décédés et qu'en
réalité on veut pas le dire et quelque
part à un moment il faudra bien qu'on
sache combien d'otages sont encore en
vie combien peuvent réellement venir moi
j'ai été le parrain de plusieurs otages
et dernièrement du petitfir sincèrement
euh je voilà dans les contacts qu'on a
avec les familles je suis pas sûr que le
petitfir Bibas qui a maintenant 1 an qui
est le plus jeune autage du monde est-ce
qu'il est encore en vie comment on
supporte ça je voudrais juste conclure
en disant demain le président Larcher
recevra les familles des victimes qui
ont été reçues aujourd'hui aux Invalides
ouis Auer Bonstein le le vous parlez des
paramètres pour peut-être un accord de
ces de ces négociations oui et moi alors
j'avais une question sur le rôle mais
vous allez certainement y répondre sur
le le rôle d'Antony binken c'est son sa
5e tournée régionale en en en 4 mois
donc ça veut dire que c'est encore quand
même les États-Unis qui détiennent une
une partie de la de la clé ben les
États-Unis ont des leviers d'influence
sur Israël que aucun autre pays n'a si
l'Europe voulait en avoir elle aurait pu
en avoir mais l'Europe n'a jamais
utilisé ses levier d'influence j'espère
qu'elle le fera prochainement pour
justement rapprocher les uns aux autres
à un accord de paix VO elle aurait pu en
avoir mais l'Europe n'a jamais utilisé
ses levier d'influence j'espère qu'elle
le fera prochainement pour
Just
les massacrer les tuer les éradiquer ce
qui veut dire ce veut dire ce qui veut
dire on cond la mort les otages il faut
être clair chaque jour qui passe il y
aura moins d'otage en vie maintenant il
y a deux il y a deux façons de je vous
interromps parce que à l'instant vous
vous disiez effectivement prise de
parole de du Premier ministre
israélien il estime que se plier aux
demandes du mouvement islamiste
palestinien ne ferait que je le cite
mener à un autre massacre donc on est
plutôt sur une sur une ligne dure
puisqueil annonce
euh avoir ordonné à l'armée de préparer
une offensive sur Rafa ça c'est ça c'est
du déclaratif il y a deux aujourd'hui il
y a de positionositions pas que le le
petit groupe de guerre comment ça
s'appelle le cabinet de guerre
aujourd'hui heureusement a été enrichi a
été renforcé par deux forces qui sont
pas les moindres qui sont monsieur
benigans et et et Monsieur eisencot les
deux exchef d'étatmajor l'un ex ministre
de la défense ils font partie de ce
cabinet c'est des gens raisonnables si
jamais si jamais natthania l'extrême
droite israélienne décide que l'objectif
c'est de continuer la guerre je peux
vous garantir que très prochainement
quitteront le gouvernement et on ira
vers une crise politique très très grave
les par tout dernier mot l'émission est
terminée tout dernier mot il il faut
accepter il faut tout faire à tout prix
pour que lesotages soient libérés on a
le temps pour détruire le Hamas c'est on
doit pas être pressé ils ont déjà reçu
des coups très très difficiles les
Palestiniens on souffrent le Hamas on
souffre ce qu'il me faut c'est les
otages à la maison et et pas de
continuer la guerreci merci beaucoup
pardon de de voir vous interrompre merci
d'avoir participé les uns et les autres
à cette émission je vous dis à bientôt
sur Public Sénat et je vous donne
rendez-vous demain 18h 22h pour un
nouveau numéro de sens public et puis
Noez que l'invité de la matinale demain
oryenement signé elle recevra cyiel
Chatelin la présidente du groupe Europe
Écologie Les Verts à l'Assemblée bonne
soirée
[Musique]